in my last video I discussed a group of
$25 decks I played with a few years back
the details aren't important but the
general idea was that my playgroup
developed a pool of budget Decks that
evolved over the course of two years and
developed its own internal metagame over
the course of that video I referred to
the boros deck of the pool as a combo
deck a graveyard Centric artifacts deck
a flexible combo deck and finally as an
eggs deck later in the video I
intentionally didn't talk about how that
deck actually functioned and this is for
the reason that it's an immensely
complex and layered deck that defies a
lot of conventional wisdom about deck
building on the surface it's not that
hard to describe what the deck is trying
to do when I posted the deck list to the
deck a while back I wrote in the
description that it was an artifact
based deck that is looking to stay alive
through Aristocrat style mid-range in
the early and mid game and eventually
launch into an egg style storm turn to
close out the game the most common way
it won was by playing a lot of artifacts
with a reckless fire Weaver in play in
order to burn out its opponents a
decidedly comprehensible game plan to
most players so where's the complexity
well the deck's convoluted nature is an
emergent factor from a number of
pressures that existed during the deck
building process and to get to those I
need to go back to that phrase eggs if
you're unfamiliar an egg is a lowcost
artifact that you can crack for a card
often played alongside egg variants that
give a card on Entry or that can be
sacrificed to give some other benefit an
eggs deck is generally one that looks to
win in a single explosive turn looping a
bunch of these eggs to generate cards
mana and other resources this is done
through cards like second Sunrise which
can recur all of the artifacts a player
sacrificed earlier in a turn thereby
netting value off of cards with effects
when they enter leave or are sacrificed
though the archetype saw enough modern
play to get one of its key cards Bann
along with several supporting cards it
hasn't seen nearly as much exploration
in Commander
however it's decidedly a possible deck
in Commander with one card above all
others bolstering the deck to being a
terrifying machine crar Clan Iron Works
this card serves a few purposes for one
it's an artifact sack Outlet which
offers easy sacrificing of artifacts
before a second sunrise and can also
allow the deck to mitigate the danger of
certain types of removal by sending
cards to the graveyard instead of a
different Zone it's also an incredible
Mana engine eggs is a storm deck at its
core one that is hungry for ways to keep
pygon cards and Mana to prolong its
storm turn and crk Clan Iron Works
basically single-handedly guarantees
that the deck will have all the
colorless Mana it could ever need on its
big turn finally as with fian alter and
ashnod's alter the card is involved in a
truly upsetting number of different
infinite combos so it's a pretty
phenomenal card able to take an eggs
deck from a modest board position to a
win in pretty short order however the
catch here is that the card is decidedly
out of the price range for a $25 deck
and it is joined in this fact by the
altars cards that could offer a similar
benefit for creature sacrificing so how
did the deck actually end up getting
built without these pivotal tools to get
into that let's take a step back and
talk about the commander my friend Hans
picked up for the deck Gerard
Weatherlight hero is a somewhat Niche
Commander from 2019 and basically what
he does is trigger a second Sunrise
effect when he dies this is nice for
adapting eggs to the commander format as
there aren't that many seconds R type
cards a fact that might otherwise pose
difficulties in a 100 card Singleton
format however the borus color identity
does pose some problems on its own a
lack of black and blue excludes some of
the more explosive wions such as
marionette master and more importantly
it mostly excludes the deck from having
access to tutors in order to get easier
access to critical cards so despite
having a potential solution for the
second Sunrise problem the deck still
had to solve the problem of needing to
draw into a sack Outlet in order to
extract full value out of its commander
and the nature of Gerard means that the
deck wants both an artifact sack outlet
and an option for sacrificing Gerard
even if we set aside the premium sack
Outlets I mentioned earlier there is
still an unfortunate pattern most of the
stronger sack Outlets were out of the
budget range for a $25 deck as of 2020
and most of the cheaper sack Outlets are
pretty mediocre either not doing much
else or requiring additional costs to
activate the deck ended up running three
artifact sacrifice Outlets ravenous
Intruder and a Talk offer a potential
Beatdown wicon in addition to being sack
outlets and slow bad can also provide
protection for key artifacts likewise
martyr's cause offers creature
protection and thermopod is a sort of
budget forian alter meaning that all
five of these have additional utility
outside their role as sack Outlets but
these numbers are decidedly not enough
for a deck where having a sack Outlet is
so fundamental to the operation so Hans
opt to supplement these with eight board
wipes that could destroy both artifacts
and creatures this is the first type of
Special Sauce that made the deck work
board wipes function as a single-use
sack outlet for all nonland permanence
allowing a full refresh of the artifacts
and creatures that the deck has on board
not only this they help address a key
problem caused by the deck lacking
access to C Clan Iron Works and the
altars it's Speed without the explosive
Mana boost provided by these sorts of
cards the deck needs to develop aot more
permanence that can generate Mana before
its loops with Gerard can become Mana
positive and allow it to fully pop off
and while this will usually happen
eventually it can take a while running a
bunch of board wipes helps with that
giving the deck tools to clear out a
concerning board that might otherwise
spell its demise this is part of why I
refer to the deck as mid-range eggs a
common play pattern for the deck is to
perform one or more isolated Loops prior
to its big turn wiping the board with
jard in play in order to slow down
opponents and generate a handful of
cards off of a developing Board of eggs
this would be an unusual choice in a lot
of more conventional eggs decks a
flagrant waste of a precious second
Sunrise effect but at a budget Point
without access to powerful cards that
would speed up the deck it's an entirely
sensible choice in this way we can see
how the budget constraint results in a
slower deck that inherently needs to
play more reactively and play more
reactively it does the de slowness gets
compounded by another factor that the
thumbnail of my last video alludes to
the fact that the pool got increasingly
aggressive over time in theory a slow
combo deck is the worst possible thing
to be against a pot of aggro decks the
explosive nature of the deck will draw
attacks from nervous opponents and the
focus on putting together the combo
rather than building a sizable board
will often leave combo decks without the
blockers needed to Stave off pressure
from opponents and indeed this was the
grizzly fate of several attempted combo
decks in the pool most notably the lazav
infect deck and the drra artifact combo
deck so how did this deck avoid that
fate well for starters a lot of the
stuff that's in the deck anyway does a
decent job at holding off aggro the deck
runs a decent number of utility
creatures it can block within a pinch
and as previously discussed the deck's
high density of board wipes discourages
aggressive opponents from fully
committing to the board in order to go
for a quick kill however as the pool got
more aggressive it nonetheless became
clear that the deck was struggling to
keep its life total from getting chipped
down before it was was able to storm off
this problem found two solutions for the
first it simply added additional
creatures cards like pilgrm zon wall of
Omens are worse than equivalent
non-creature artifacts in a game without
opponents but when you consider what an
asset blockers can be for Staying Alive
they become more justifiable Beyond
these the addition of cards like revelar
vesperlark and Sun Titan offered both
additional blockers and a more robust
grind Factor not only did these cards
allow the deck to exist comfortably in
the pre-storm phase for longer the deck
also ends up with a non-storm game plan
that's powerful enough to compete and
win on its own as long as an opponent
hasn't pulled too far ahead opponents
might even feel the need to pull the
trigger on using removal and graveyard
hate during the deck's mid-range phase
which then opens the door to rebuild and
storm off without the Obstacle of that
interaction with all this context in
mind how exactly did this eggs deck end
up being such a complex deck and such a
challenging deck to play well on the
surface there are some decision chains
that exist for toolbox combo decks in
general such as how early to play a
developing card like a tutor and what to
search for with it there are also some
difficulties in knowing exactly when to
attempt a storm turn and when not to
however I'd wager that the most
difficult thing about this deck is its
sheer flexibility and the way it Blends
mechanical complexity and strategic
complexity on a purely mechanical level
performing various tasks with this deck
requires a fine attention to detail and
and optimizing a turn that has
potentially dozens of different possible
play paths can require a lot of
concentration even for an experienced
pilot of the deck at the same time as
this the deck blend of mid-range control
and storm elements means that a player
must simultaneously balance a whole host
of strategic factors are opponents doing
something that demands the deck comp
with an answer or something that implies
that opponent has hate the deck should
play around if an opponent is playing
aggressively should the deck dig in its
heels and play defensively or would
doing so slow it down to where a
different opponent is able to get too
far ahead is an opponent's game plan
scaling to where the deck needs to storm
off in an approaching turn in order to
avoid losing and would setting up for
that storm turn expose the deck to
attacks or hate cards is the deck even
capable of storming off in that time
frame even a decision as simple as
whether to sacrifice an egg can have big
implications sacrificing it might allow
the deck to dig for useful cards and
keep its card velocity up but each egg
sacrificed weakens Gerard's loops and
sacrificing too many may leave the deck
with two few eggs to begin storming off
in a reasonable time frame ultimately
it's this combination of macro and micro
that makes the deck so difficult to play
a pilot of the deck needs to consider
the merits of a number of different play
paths but each of those play paths
involves dozens of different decisions
along with a number of probabilistic
factors so figuring out the correct
decision can involve thinking multiple
turns in advance down play paths which
each individually have a tremendous
amount of complexity and elements to
consider finding its way to a win can
feel like threading the needle where
there are countless factors to balance
and where a single tiny mistake can Doom
the deck to failure for this reason the
deck was by far the hardest to play of
any of the decks in the deck pool I
talked about last video as the resident
combo player and the person who built
the deck Hans had a 28% win rate with it
over the course of all the games with it
while all other players had a collective
19% win rate with the deck even once I
knew the deck well enough to win with it
I still slow played like crazy because
the task of finding the way to a win is
so inherently packed with difficulty
even for an experienced pilot of the
deck in that way the deck was probably
not the most ideal as a part of a public
deck pool but it was an insanely cool
deck at the correct power level so it
wasn't like we were going to dismantle
it there are plenty of Concepts that are
gestured to by a deck like this but
perhaps the most pronounced is what it
says about what makes decks complex in
the first place a lot of EDH players
seem to have the mindset that higher
powered decks are going to be inherently
more interesting more layered more
complicated and as a matter of averages
they're not necessarily wrong your
average cedh deck is going to involve a
lot more decision-making and is going to
leverage player skill much more
seriously than your average midow battle
cruiser deck but this Factor isn't
inherent to power level or budget or
deck speed primarily a deck's complexity
relates to two factors how difficult it
is for the deck to complete various
tasks and how hard a deck needs to try
to navigate around its opponents your
average cedh game is certainly going to
involve a whole lot of that second one
due to the nature of competitive EDH but
on the other hand thoral consultation is
pretty piss easy as far as ways to win
the game go there's more complexity
involved in finishing off opponents with
slivers or ER Dragon than a two-card
instant win combo likewise if we
consider the hypothetical non-budget
eggs deck that runs Clark Clan Iron
Works and ways to tutor for it it's
naturally going to be easier than the
budget verion on both of these axes
winning is easier because KCI
effortlessly bypasses most issues that
might slow the deck storm plan and
navigating around opponents is also
easier because there's no need to engage
with the board the that could add in a
healthy Suite of protection removal and
potential blockers but as with most
storm decks it's almost certainly better
to focus on speed and streamlining the
deck's proactive plan rather than
fussing over whatever opponents are
doing by contrast $25 mid-range eggs is
a far more layered complex and
challenging deck specifically because it
lacks cards that effortlessly solve the
problems that lay between it and victory
forcing it to engage with what the rest
of the table is doing and Tackle
problems in a more creative way as a
similar example there's a player my LGS
who plays a reasonably powerful J and
Jansen deck but he doesn't run clock of
Omens in it a JJ Deck with clock of
Omens is generally going to be a
moderately fiddly combo deck there's
complexity in how the deck generates
resources and performs the setup it
needs but once the deck is ahead winning
will often just mean grabbing clock and
a way to turn the commander into an
artifact and then generating an
arbitrary amount of whatever resource is
needed to kill opponents now a Jan
Jansen deck without clock of Omens isn't
a fiddly deck the deck and the fiddle
are one in the same and just about any
simple task you can imagine requires the
deck approximately 12 game actions to
complete minimum this isn't necessarily
a more valid or less valid way to build
the deck though I might pause it that
it's the most appropriate one for a true
Jan Jansen player if you live for the
fiddle why win with a combo when you can
instead win by fiddling harder than
anybody previously thought possible this
principle applies broadly to Casual EDH
for any given task there will be easier
and harder ways to accomplish it and
sometimes it might make a deck feel
better to oper a solution that's not the
easiest one the most obvious example of
this is ways to win the game I know a
lot of EDH players who have gone through
a phase of trying to make a deck they
like as good as possible up to end
including throwing lots of Power Cards
and infinite combos into it then a
couple months into chasing this goal un
questioningly they look at the deck
they've ended up with and realize that
the things about the deck they really
liked have been lost in the shuffle the
same can be true for Value generation
the strongest options in general are
going to be your set and forget engines
like the one ring and ristic study but
these are also plain predictable and
often entirely disconnected from the
rest of what a deck is doing if you're
building a cedh deck deck these make
sense as a starting point since they're
the most powerful options but magic is
filled with lots of other options that
are far more interesting what about an
explosive but spicy option like
necrologia or a synergistic value engine
like scrap troler or some modal instant
speed draw options for a more control
oriented deck if the creative process of
figuring out how to pull aead in value
is interesting to you playing draw you
actually like at a slightly lower power
level may be a much more enjoyable
experience than relying on generic
Staples at a high high power level
likewise if you have a task you want to
accomplish in a straightforward way it
can make sense to boost the power of
your cards for that specific task in my
Francisco Malcolm deck I spend a hefty
chunk of budget on several generic
relatively powerful tutors because
finding my combo pieces is an area of my
deck I don't want to fuss around with by
contrast the draw and counter spells in
the deck are a lower power but more
carefully tuned to the deck's specific
needs and play patterns and this ends up
feeling good for the way I want the deck
to play as another example Hans has a
midow chainer deck that has all sorts of
ridiculous and fiddly synergies but it
runs most of the powerful monoblock
acceleration because everything in the
deck is extremely Mana intensive so
without a massive amount of Mana the
deck feels slow and Toothless as EDH
players we often think about power level
on a deck wide basis you know is it high
power is it low power is it cedh and
this framework can be useful at giving a
snapshot of a deck but digging into how
efficient each different component of a
deck is and being intentional about the
relative power of different parts of a
deck can lead to Decks that are more fun
to play asking what sort of experience
you're looking for out of a deck and
tailoring the components of it to match
that experience is a step that can and
will lead to more enjoyable decks and
games thanks for watching if you like
what I do here and would pay money for
even more of it you can head over to my
patreon there I have seven fulllength
bonus videos along with five end notes
to videos here where I discuss related
topics that didn't make the cut for the
final script Patron money goes toward
making sure that I always have plenty of
delicious eggs to eat as well as toward
paying my rent and letting me buy pretty
basic lands all equally important tasks
if you ask me